in this video we'll introduce cokes
which is a python package for
reinforcement learning
um and the goal is to make it easy to
turn rl papers into code
so why do we build cokes well first of
all the target audience is rl
researchers and practitioners
and we wanted to make it easy to turn
papers into code because we wanted to
be able to do quick iterations on our
experiments and basically to try and
sort of hot swap different components
and to try out different
kinds of agents and i don't know about
you but if i
see a talk about the software package
and i don't see any code i get a bit
frustrated so i thought i'd just sort of
change it around
show some code not that you need to
understand any of it
so it's quite a lot but don't read it
the
goal of showing you this code is to show
the general structure so the structure
on the left
is the same as a structure on the right
and that's important to note here
because
the idea is is to take some pseudocode
from a paper
and then turn them into a working code
that reads almost the same as the
pseudocode so it really so
the the structure here is well the idea
is to show that
um the amount of complexity that you see
on the left which is the pseudo
algorithm or the pseudo code for
uh for the dqn agent that that that
structure the complexity
is equal to the structure and complexity
on the right
now coax has a slightly different design
from other
rl frameworks and we'll just highlight
two
and one is the the neural network
architecture and the other one is
how we deal with a training loop um
so the neural network architecture is a
first-class citizen
in in cokes and here's an example of the
actual queue function that we use to
play atari video games
so it's just a couple of convolutions
and
and then some fully connected layers and
you see it's just
fully fully transparent what's going on
here
so we basically just define the forward
pass function called func here
and then the q function just takes that
forward pass function and turns it into
something that we can actually use as a
q function so
so for instance here we would define
this q function
and as an example we'll just take a
state action pair and then feed it into
this q
function and you just get a floating
point if you give it a pair
and also if the action space is discrete
you can omit the
the actions as well um
and then another part of where to sort
of emphasize how you're in control is
that
some in some packages it can be very
difficult to figure out exactly what
is uh running and where it's running and
and what's exactly happening and
in cokes we just got away with uh we did
wave all of that
um so here we just so the the user is in
control of uh
effect of saying exactly when and and
how the function approximators are
updated
so coax is built around concepts uh like
value functions and policies and that
sort of thing but
but not around agents so it has a notion
of an agent but it's basically
uh like other packages are centered
around agents
where i think it just doesn't really
quite work because it's too high level
just to illustrate this point on the
left here you see the implementation of
the dqn agent
uh as done in tf agents
um where you just see a whole bunch of
arguments and flags that you need to set
but it's not very clear from the context
of
of the code what those flags do so you
have to basically go back to the paper
and try and figure out what is going on
and the goal of cokes is to not really
have to read back that you can actually
read the code and understand what it
does
and on the right it's even even worse
it's our
lib it's um our lib is sort of
centered around configuration files
which is useful if you want to do big
parameter sweeps
but it's very painful if you want to
implement your own agent so it
it's it's very quickly it becomes very
hard to
to debug um
so because coax gets rid of this idea of
an agent
we do want to sort of fill that gap by
implementing
uh showing how to implement certain
agents in cogs
um and so we we offered these
these things called stubs agent stubs
which are just
sort of a very simple skeleton for
building an agent and you can just copy
it and
and just put in the specific environment
that you're interested in and there's
your agent
under the hood this uses a jackson xla
xla is a hardware acceleration for
linear
algebra operations so basically quick
operations on tpus and gpus
and jax is a way to basically it has an
alternative implementation of numpy
that also has automatic differentiation
and is written on top of xla which makes
it very
fast and also automatically
differentiable so it's a very
lightweight
version of or alternative to tensorflow
and
pytorch um so it's it's fast and it's
flexible it's uh
and everything is is very explicit so
it's it's a very nice package to work
with
so let me now go so now that i've
introduced the package let me just
quickly
give a little example of how to build an
agent
in this demo we'll get to see how to get
started with cokes
the the environment that we'll solve is
not very complicated in fact it's the
easiest one that i could find and the
reason is that
um i wanted to focus on uh the
components of cokes more than the
the specific details of of an
environment so and
the frozen lake in fact we'll take the
non-slippery version of the frozen lake
uh which is just a four by four grid you
start at the top left
and you sort of work your way to the
bottom right at least that's the goal
and
and we're going to do reinforcement
learning to
to make that happen um obviously it's
not very impressive because it's not
all that complicated of a task but we'll
see that the exact same
techniques also work on much more
sophisticated environments
and in the documentation you find other
examples of more sophisticated agents
and more intricate kind of
tasks but for now we'll just focus on a
very simple one to keep it simple and
brief
so we'll start by importing the packages
that we need that's jim
so it's jax for our arrays it's
haiku for our neural networks
and its optics for our optimization
and then of course coax itself we start
by defining our environment
uh which we define which is called the
frozen lake non-slippery
and then just we'll just have a quick
look at the observation space
and the action space so the observation
space is
a 4x4 grid which is represented by just
an integer
and the action space as well so we've
got up down left right
and so we'll start the actual
episode rollout loop by starting with
our initial state from the reset
and then for time step t in the maximum
episode steps um we'll just run our
rollout so we sample an action for now
because we don't really have a policy to
sample from
and then we'll take one step in the mdp
and
here is where we normally would do our
updates
uh we don't do it right now so and then
we break out of the loop before you're
done
um now we can run this but obviously it
doesn't do anything so let's render
and indeed we see that it's and the
agent sort of walks straight into a hole
right so the next step is to try and
figure out um
what to basically build a queue function
that we can use to select actions
so the queue function will use the queue
class
for which we will feed in a forward pass
function
and the environment which is used to
check the the input and output structure
of the forward pass function
so the forward pass function we define
as our state action pair
and a flag that says whether we're
training or not
and we have two options when the action
space is discrete which is to either
feed in a state action pair and output a
scalar
or take a state action or to just take a
state and then output a vector
where each entry of the vector is is the
value associated with an output action
um so that's what we'll do here actually
um
so we'll take we'll remove the uh the
input a
and then we'll output the vector so
let's just
drop this
drop this a right sorry
and then we output the number of actions
and uh obviously we need to also
initialize this as zero just to give a
uh a fair sort of entry point to the to
the learning process
um so we can evaluate the q function on
the state action pair and if the action
space is discrete we can also just omit
the action altogether so that's nice
to go from a queue a function to a
policy we can take
either a epsilon greedy or a boltzmann
policy so value-based policy
and i personally prefer baltimore policy
because it's a little less finicky
and here we can just uh feed the state
into
uh into the policy and it's it's a
probabilistic function so you see that
it has different
outputs so now we can replace the random
sampling by uh the sampling done by the
policy which is still random so we'll
still actually end up in a hole here
um other than that it works just
just the same so what we're going to do
now is define how we're going to update
this q function so we'll take the q
learning
algorithm from the td learning module
and one of the things to note here is
that the update
method that we'll use requires a
transition batch
and we don't have that yet so we need to
define a way to do that
so we'll define a tracer which is just a
simple n-step tracer
and the n-step tracer will just take a
single step
td step and we'll take a discount factor
of 0.9
and then what we can do is we can
actually start
start doing running our updates so the
first thing that we can do is um
is we can just take a raw transition
and feed it into the n-step tracer
and the n-step tracer will evaluate the
true
if it has something to pop if you can
pop a transition from it so that's what
we'll do here
and then that transition we then feed
back into the q learning algorithm
so that's how we do our updates and
and then we're we're basically done
except that of course
we don't want to render at every step
because uh if we're going to
take many steps namely it will take
about 500 episodes
um and then we can run uh in fact
so uh we're not really seeing any logs
here and
coax does have a nice train monitor um
wrapper that we can use to uh to
actually display the
the logs so we may want to restart real
quick and then
start running it and then you'll see
that uh here we actually see in the
standard error of the uh
of the cell that that we're actually
learning and we
see the average g go up slightly
so finally to finish off by um actually
rendering the episode
with the policy not just the policy but
agree
policy uh which is the most and indeed
we see that it end to the goal state
all right so that was a really quick uh
walkthrough of
how to put the different pieces of cokes
together
um if you want to look at different
examples
just have a look at all of the examples
here listed so
so for instance here are the atari games
there's a couple of agents on there so
maybe if you want to see
ppo run on atari here's a nice little
script that shows you exactly how to do
that
so it's the same same structure but a
few more components so here is an actor
critic so you have an updater for your
actor as well as for your critics so
that's that's the same kind of thing but
all right um well thanks for watching
and have fun with cokes